the world's largest retailer Amazon
Amazon Amazon Amazon Amazon Amazon
Amazon
is now
[Music]
1000 employees are getting fired
starting this year
Amazon wants their employees to resign
this might sound counter-intuitive but
it's true it turns out that for Amazon
it's actually beneficial to constantly
turn through employees this is actually
one of the main reasons that Amazon
treats their employees so poorly whether
it be exposing warehouse workers to
safety hazards making their drivers pee
in bottles or working Tech stuff to the
Bone Amazon does it all and it looks
like their efforts of creating a
terrible working environment are playing
out perfectly in fact Amazon's turnover
rate is so high that they measure it on
a weekly basis Amazon loses
approximately three percent of their
warehouse workers every single week this
translates to an annual turnover rate of
a hundred and fifty percent in other
words Amazon's entire Warehouse
Workforce is replaced basically every
eight months and considering the working
conditions of these people this rate is
not too surprising but why in the world
would Amazon want their employees to
resign they likely spend thousands if
not to tens of thousands of dollars on
recruiting each into every one of their
employees and let's not forget all of
the time and resources they spent on
onboarding and training employees so it
doesn't really make sense to sign them
on it just for two-thirds of warehouse
workers to leave in 90 days and that
their Tech workers to live in two years
right wrong it turns out that constantly
turning to employees is not only cheaper
for Amazon but substantially more
productive in fact Jeff Bezos has gone
as far as declaring that a tenured
Workforce is simply a march to
mediocrity as employees become more
tenured they tend to also become more
comfortable and more lazy or at least
that's what Amazon thinks so over the
years Amazon has perfected how to
attract employees and push them away at
the same time essentially they want you
to come in with their Big Dreams work
your ass off for two years rely that no
one recognizes your efforts and then
leave so that the neck sucker can come
in and do the exact same thing they've
basically mastered the art of running a
Cutthroat meat grinder so here's the
Twisted economics of Amazon and the
downright putrid tactics they use to
screw over their employees
foreign
pushes out blue collar workers and it's
not really rocket science they basically
create a high pressure high stress
environment with lofty targets and no
downtime but the way they handle their
Tech workers is a lot more interesting
as you know Tech workers demand a pretty
lofty salary so Amazon has to employ
some pretty clever yet disgusting
strategies likely the most notable of
these strategies is screwing over their
employees with a wonky vesting periods
if you're not familiar with vesting
periods and it's basically how much time
you have to wait until you can cash in
on your stock compensation most tech
companies operate under a four-year
vesting schedule with stock competition
being evenly split up across the years
at Facebook for example employees get 25
of their total stock rent every year
with 6.25 being unlocked every quarter
Google actually takes it to another
level in terms of vesting they not only
front load their stock vesting but they
do investing on a monthly basis so it's
almost like a monthly salary Amazon
however does the exact opposite as they
backload their vesting Engineers have to
wait a full year just for five percent
of their stock to vest and another full
year just for 15 the best it's not until
the third and fourth years that
Engineers actually receive 80 of their
promised stock this might not sound like
a big deal but if you enter Amazon at a
relatively senior level it really screws
you over for example let's say you have
the option to enter Google as an L6 and
Amazon as an L7 which are approximately
equal positions in terms of work and
responsibilities on paper both companies
pay approximately the same amount just
over five hundred thousand dollars
Amazon actually pays thirty thousand
dollars more but if you made your
decision based on these Topline numbers
you'd be making a mistake and here's why
this stock Brand number of 318 thousand
dollars is not something that you
receive every year it's just an average
of what you'll receive over the next
four years so Amazon is basically
offering you 1.27 million for the next
four years and at vests according to the
schedule the same thing applies to
Google but given that they have a much
more fair vesting schedule it's not
really to your disadvantage in fact here
I saw both the jobs break down over four
years during year one Google pays 611
000 while Amazon pays 306 thousand
dollars three hundred and six thousand
dollars is obviously not a bad amount
but it's only half of Google despite
Amazon's compensation seeming like it
was actually higher than Google's during
year two Google will pay another 611
thousand dollars while Amazon will pay
433 thousand dollars during year three
Google drops to 506 000 while Amazon
Rockets the 750 000 and during the last
year Google drops further to 401
thousand dollars while Amazon stays
constant at 750. if you're wondering why
Google's compensation drops over the
years it's because they're betting that
the stock price will increase by the
time you receive it so when you account
for stock growth your compensation
should be relatively stable at Google
Amazon will of course also explain
appearance stock growth so their
compensation in the last two years will
likely be over a million but you can bet
that they're gonna do everything they
can to push you out in the first two
years
foreign
statistically speaking neither the
average Google nor the average Amazon
Tech worker reaches two years the
average tenure at Google is 1.9 years
while the average tenure at Amazon is
1.84 years so not a big difference in
terms of employee retention but the
difference in compensation is night and
day given that Google has monthly
vesting an employee leaving at 1.9 years
has actually vested over 60 percent of
their stock an employee at Amazon living
at 1.84 years however won't have even
investor their year 2 stock as they have
to finish the year so they're left with
just the five percent that was vested
after year one in other words remember
that massive 1.27 million dollar stock
grant that Amazon offered you when you
joined well the average Amazonian will
only end up receiving a mere 63 000 of
this the average googler would have
received a 571 thousand dollars worth of
their stock compensation when you
annualize these numbers along with the
base salary and the bonus you'll see
that the googler was earning an
effective salary of 611 000 others while
the Amazonian was only earning 274
thousand dollars or less than half of
what the compensation appeared to be
again you can't really complain with
either of these salaries but you can see
just how misleading Amazon's Top Line
number was now I shouldn't note that
Amazon sometimes offers a large cash
bonus during year one to make up for
some of this Gap but that only goes so
far and doesn't apply to everyone why
not just stick around for four years
then you'll get the full promised amount
right well the reality is that this is
extremely difficult due to the ax AKA
Pips Pips stands for performance
Improvement plans and Amazon swears by
these through these plans Amazon ranks
all of their employees every single year
and then they go ahead and fire the
bottom 10 every single year and as you
would guess this policy
disproportionately affects new hires and
it creates an extremely toxic work
culture basically all of your team
members will be trying to backstab you
so that they're not the ones who are put
on these performance Improvement plans
everyone is trying to survive the
two-year cliff and cash in on the stock
competition that's so close yet so far
away the reality though is that the
average employee doesn't even pass two
years but let's assume that you're part
of a lucky view who make it through the
full four years congratulations you got
a big payday but now Amazon still wants
you to leave if you survive the first
four years it's unlikely that they'll
put you on a performance Improvement
plan and force you out that way but what
they will do is severely Nerf your pay
and hope that you either leave or stay
in the work for substantially lower pay
either option is okay with them how do
they do this you ask well remember that
massive stock grant that they offered
you when you joined well let's just say
you ain't getting that again if you're
lucky you may get stock Refreshers but
that's usually nothing in comparison to
your compensation in year three and four
if you are an L7 for example your
compensation will drop from nearly a
million down to 300 000 and you're
expected to maintain this same level of
output if you want to continue avoiding
the Pips by this point though most
remaining amazonians don't want to put
up with this anymore so if the Pips
didn't get them the nerve to pay it
usually does
foreign
if things are so unfair at Amazon though
why do people still join well for
delivery drivers and warehouse workers
it's often the only job they're able to
find but what about the tech workers
surely they're smart enough to see
through these tricks and do their
research right well they are most of
them know all about this but they choose
to join anyway because Amazon is
oftentimes the only thing job that
they're able to land of course they
could go ahead and join a respectable
background company like Visa or Oracle
but that won't make the same impact on
their career trajectory that Amazon
would you see no Tech worker is putting
up with all this just to work on Amazon
retail all the hype for Tech workers is
to get into AWS or Amazon web services
if you're not familiar with AWS they're
the gold standard when it comes to cloud
computing and infrastructure AWS holds a
market share of 41.5 percent in the
cloud computing Market which is more
than their main competitors combined
Microsoft comes in at 29.4 percent while
Google comes in at amuse Lee 2.6 percent
as such everyone in the cloud space is
looking for X AWS employees in fact many
job postings will literally list AWS
experience as a minimum qualification so
many Tech workers figure that putting up
with Amazon is their best shot at
potentially Landing a job at a
non-abusive fan company and more times
than not this actually does work out
many of the people who leave Amazon
after 1.84 years aren't actually getting
fired through pip rather they were
offered an opportunity to join apple or
Google's Cloud departments and if you
want any proof regarding just how badly
these people want to leave Amazon just
look at all the money they're leaving on
the table in year three and four Amazon
doesn't take this as an insult though
they're happy to be a springboard for
other fan companies as at the end of the
day they're the ones who got the most
labor for the cheapest price and within
the tech side of Amazon I don't think
this will be changing anytime soon but
it may be changing on the blue color
side you see you when you're a small
company and you're turning to a bunch of
employees it's not really a big deal but
when you're at Amazon size with over a
million employees you actually run the
risk of running out of people to turn
through and ironically this is the exact
crisis that Amazon has been facing since
mid-2021 according to leaked internal
research Amazon will run out of
warehouse workers to turn through by
2024 which at this point is only eight
months away a looming recession may give
Amazon some more time but sooner or
later they'll have to confront the
consequences of turning through so many
people
foreign
the reason Amazon wants their employees
to resign it simply comes down to
productivity and financials they believe
that the most productive employees are
the ones that have just joined or have
something to prove so they structure all
of their compensation plans and
corporate performance policies around
milking out these first few years of
productivity for as cheap as possible
everything from their compensation
policy investing schedule to their
performance Improvement plans and work
culture is all designed to get Engineers
to join but not stay for Long by this
point most Engineers are well aware of
the harsh reality of Amazon but Amazon
is able to Leverage The reputation of
AWS to continue recruiting Engineers on
the warehouse side of things though
they're up for a massive challenge not
too long from now but only time will
tell how they handled this situation and
that's why Amazon wants their employees
to resign did you know about these
clever yet disgusting tactics comment
that down below also drop a like if you
hope that Amazon is forced to change
things for the better and of course
consider checking out our Discord
ideas and to consider subscribing to see
more questions at logically answered but
until then I'm Hari and I'll see you
guys on the next one
foreign
thank you